les séries j'ai un autre
jeu qui va manger le
slip qui veut jouer à qui veut manger le
slip qui veut
jouer les Chéries les Chéries c'est très
simple non mais qui met le slip dis Non
Non mais alors attendez on va tirer au
sort celui qui met on va tirer au sort
celui qui met le
SP on va tirer au sort celui qui met le
slip et on va tirer au sort celui qui
mange Arte arrête
arrêtetion je je vous le dis je vais
demander aux filles si veulent bien le
faire pour
une sera un me qui va mettre maisère il
y a pas de c'est que des bonbons non non
non
je suis pas sûr que ça passe laaffaire
au
CAG il y a pas beaucoup d'tim les chér
les Chéries je vous demande juste une
question qui veut participer à qui veut
manger
aussi F toi tu tu peux mais tu as envie
c'est oui oui t'inquiète pas pour pour
le manger voilà donc non Bernard non
Meur non alors très bien alors donc on
est
gadine vous ne partici pas mange le SP
également c'est ton
dro c'est cholestérol déjà choisir celui
qui va mettre le slip ça sera en une
fois avec les chiffres tous ceux qui
participent on va démarrer par
Jean-Michel je vais commencer à compter
par Jean-Michel attention point de
règlement on met le slip par-dessus le
pantalon oUI NON à
poil celui qui met le slip va devoir
enlever le slip là-bas non enlever
justement là il le met sur son sur son
calçon mais sur Oui gars oui oui qu Mme
sachez sachez que je joue je
joue jou pour manger et pour mettre je
joue je va je vais compter aussi tqu pas
je peux tout faire no pour manger et et
pour mettre les deux pour manger c'est
un délire je fais le truc
pour ce qu'on dit depu une dem c'est pas
la personne
quiors attention je jou je derni à
compter en fait d'accord attention 3 2 1
ceux qui participent vas-y chiffre 4 g
tu joues non non j'ai dit non ah tu
joues
pas jouer mais t'emmerd pas si tu veux
pas jouer si tu veux pas
jouer tu jou tu joues tu joues tu joues
att TOS tu joue juste pour manger tu
joue pour manger m manger il jou pour
manger attention
attention il y a pas de fille qui joue
il 4 + 5 5 + 3 8 8 + 3 11 ah tu joues
finalement 15 tu m'as
dit c'est pour porter 14 et 3 17 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 gardez les mains pour qu'il
sache qui 12 13 14 15
[Applaudissements]
16 touche donc comme saute comme on
saute Momo non non non non on prend on
prend toujours celui qui est avant le
choisi c'est donc HUG h tu
vas
va j'ai mis un caleçon
gris on va voir la bossse qui va
manger
qui veut participer qui veut manger le
CIP de Hugo Raymon a dit qu'il voulait
participer he ou oui ah ça y est c'est
un
comm c'est sûr après il y en a assez
pour tout le monde he si vous voulez
tous
bouffer j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression que ça se bouscule
au là vous avez tous envie de jouer hein
pour Mang j'ai le slip bon
allez ça fait des
semaines sinon il y a personne vous
allez pas jouer à de é plusile pour les
cornichons
1 3 6 non 3 et 4 7 c'est benim ça va au
niveau ch 7 7 + de 9 11 et 3 10 1 2
j'ura mettre un non 4 5 moi je
mets 6 7 8 9
[Applaudissements]
non non ça va aller t'inquiète ça va
bien se
passer allez vas-y j'ai même pas regardé
comment tu
compé je te donne je qu'on me donne le
slep l'envie d'avoir mon slep faut que
je fasse le r Je mets là je m'en fous
non non non vas-y allez va mettre le
slip toi tu te
prépares allez faut que ququ M parce que
je sais pas comment tu te prépares toi
tu te prépares non mais tu vas où comme
ça ça je vais
[Applaudissements]
vérifier ça je crois qu'on va assoer à
une séquence myique ah oui ou les gars
c'est on a quand même fait ça fait une
heure qu'on fait sur les cadeaux et on a
pas fin j'ai même pas fini d'ailleurs
j'ai même pas fini alors je vais finir
les cadeaux pendant qu'il se il se
change oui fais voir ton cadeau monsieur
vous l'avez promis oh
ouis c'est pas mal une voiture j'
prendis une voiture attendsattends
attends attends pourquoi elle est cassée
là elle est pas cassée c'est mais tu te
fous de ma gueule quoi mais a les rétros
pétés c'est quoi cette merde le bon coin
mais c'est quoi cette merde les rétros
ils sont
pétés fais voir ton cadeau alors moi il
y a quelque chose dont vous parlez
beaucoup dans l'émission j'ai peur que
elle vous manque pendant 15 jours donc
je vous offre ma chatte ça vient du
cœur et voilà vous penserez à moi
je pense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que allez bien ça va bien se
[Applaudissements]
passer
les règles c'est les
règles une règle du je c'est une règle
du
jeu sil
plat stop s'il vous plaît je su stop non
mais père dans quelle émission tuentend
Mang m le S mangei le S mangei le slip
mangei le
[Applaudissements]
SP mais non mais ici ici au niveau de là
là là c'est collé quand même au niveau
de là c'est collé quand même je touche
un bon si je touche un bon juré j'ai pas
eu chaud avant si je mange un bonbon je
mange pas qu'un bonbon non non non c'est
très très
collé non non non
me finit les cadeaux finmiss alors toi
tu sa quoi tu mets tu te mets là tu te
mets là devant devant tu te mets là
devant rmon voilà tranquille tu attends
et on finit on finit les cadeaux on
finit les cadeaux s'il vous plaît on se
calme pensez à vous vraiment pour le
coup parce que tout ça c'est une arnaque
est-ce que vous aimez est-ce que vous
aimezè tain enlève t mains regarde un VO
un peu
je suis au
régime il est diabétique il est
diabétique il est diabétique il pe pas
c'est des bonbon sans sucre t'inquiète
la vie elle est fol la vie elle est
inroable on l'aurait écrit on l'aurait
pas fait que ça on l'écrition on la fait
pasent quand il est assis c'est moins
gênant que debout je me demande raison
plus gênant moi me me comme ça je mets
commass comme ça
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine demain j'imagine demain quand
il va livrer oh il y a le mangeur de
slip ça va ça changé ta il va il va
clner un mec qui avance pas quand il est
e tu fa le malin quand tu
fais je J je te jure c'est long Ron par
contre donc parce que tu sais plus c'est
long plus je suis mal à l'aise là allez
vas-y he ça va bien ça te va bien ça va
bien alors c est-ce que vous aimez être
tripoté non mais non mais moi pas du
tout malaxé oui mais ça dépend par ma
oui par par ma meuf oui est-ce que vous
vous aimeriez pas lâcher prise mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait un massage je
déteste ça alors attendez c'est pas un
massage non mais c'est pas un massage du
corps justement vous allez rester
habillé tout habillé c'est un massage
cobido du visage pendant une heure on va
ouais pour justement alors vous avez pas
de ride mais c'est justement pour
drainer massage ancestral pendant une
heure avec maat
avit qui pouvit
mero je prends le massage il prend les
[Applaudissements]
bonbonszz faireasser j'adore mon
faireasser on change non mais vous allez
adorer vous allez voir c'est une extase
je vais l'essayer elle va vous étirer le
visage elle va vous drainer elle va elle
va
déc
2024 comvec ça va les yeux ça va les
yeux plît un petit PL
pour merci r alors je suis sûr que ça va
te plaire j'ai tapé dans le mil si ça
vous plaît vous annulez c'est vous qui
mangez Leig PLA c'est obligé que ça te
plaise Mo il a déj bah oui à toi c'est
ta
chemise est
belle c'est ma
chemise oui oui mais je jamais mise moi
jamais
pas ah bon
[Applaudissements]
je suis reparti un matin à 6h du mat
avec c'est à moi bah écoute regarde
regarde com
je va prend merci de cadeau tu vas
bouffer toi j'ai un cadeau c c j'ai un
cadeau c'est insupportable ah oui
c'est
allezne ton cadeau le
confuseur V je arriv là donne ton cadeau
là tiens
cy ça ça sent c'est lourd c'est lourd
fais gaffe prendsle c'est lourd lour le
vrai beau cadeau ça ouis ça c'est
vraii premier degré ouais ah ouais très
beau cadeau si si si Cyril non mais
arrête c'est mérité non maisr tu l'as
non mais arrête attends 13 ans de TPMP
des millions de téléspectateurs des f
rir ça se fait un set
d'or c'est celui de
Laurent Laurent il t'a volé
[Applaudissements]
tnorme ça prenait la poussière non mais
mais il t'
volé par contre faut pas prendre ça dans
le cul tu sais pas si çaas pas déjà
visité la
grotte non mais merci non va mér comme
ça tu vois de la voir là comme ça c'est
ah ou c'est c'est un
obetner merci ça de la gueule tuas un
cadeau pour moi moi j'ai un discours à
te faire un discours trop mignon le plus
beau cadeau
ça ch ça faait 7 ans que je te
connais devant les caméras et derrière
les caméras tu m'as jamais laisser
tomber Mme soir j'ai cétait en galère
dans sur tu m'as envoyé ton C du cur
et je veux dire à Madame
Anouna madame Anouna merci d'avoir mis
unnce au
[Applaudissements]
mondeir
incroyable il
fa es con tu vas faire chou le
[__] c'est n'orte quoi
[Applaudissements]
transition allez merci bobo on va
bouffer les allez on va bouffer les
SP sur ce c'est bien genti mom
[Applaudissements]
mais sur ce sur ce belle
parole sur le colé allez la télé c'est
qui de la
télé salut les chéries
Chud imaginez vous pourriez le faire
vous B voilà il y a pas beaucoup
franchement vous abusez ça va je suis
propr
franchement attention après il est une
autre propositionité quand même sinon
non peut pas cé sur le côé
personnellement si personne bouffe un B
je ser vexé je vous
dis sur le côté les gars ça va
respireer tu l'enlèves et il le
mange si vous voulez mais bon la fête
est moins folle
retire pas ton
slip la chaîne
tu veux aller vas-y bouffesenle avant
par contre si tu peux manger ah ouais
c'est c'est pas pas voilà ça a bien
trouré sur mes chaussures ouais mais
attends ou mais là il y a plus d'intérêt
ouais doncoi tu veux vraiment lui
bouffer non mais moi c'est la chaîne je
m'en fous moi c'est pas c'est c'est vous
si vousz probl al il faut qu'on demande
à la chaîne s'il peut te bouffer le
SK remets-le remets-le je je j'appelle
je pense que c'est possible fait chier
[__] côé écz Mo écoutez où vous voulez
je m'en fous ça me dérange pas
excusez-moi est-ce que la chaîne est là
s'il plîdique de la chaî on alors on a
problème est-ce que la est-ce que vous
pouvez m'envoyer quelqu'un de la chaîne
de la conformité pour voir si on peut on
peutain de chercher dans le bouquin
est-ce qu'on peut non non non la
conformité la conformité ouais c'est
drôle conformité c'est drôle conformité
conformité je veux quelqu' d'formité
pour savoir si on peut bouffer un slip à
l'antenne à 19h4 on est d'accord que toi
ça te pose aucun problème et tu moi je
prends limite du plaisir il y a pas de
problème d'accordjà déjà le consentement
des deux côtés éta moi niveau
consentement il on y
diabétique si je peux me permettre
rajoute ça dans ton
slip bah de c'est suffisant
alors est-ce qu'on a quelun la
conformité qui arrive merci pour savoir
ils sont en train de bouquiner là pour
voir AR tire 22 est-ce que est-ce que
c'est déjà arrivé desjà en télé est-ce
qu'il y a déjà des précéd première
mondiale je pense c'est une première
Modelle mais est-ce qu'un SIP a déjà été
bouffé télvision récupère les balles de
pingpong après ou pas je suis pas sûr
que je vais jouer beaucoup
avec donc attends d'abord les questions
est-ce que toi ça te dérange de te faire
bouffer le slip ça me dérange pas ça me
fait plaisir
d'accord très bien euh
Raymon c'est une j'ai jamais fait ça
mais on peut voir sur les sur le latéral
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire je peux
pas manger trop de sucre moi à cause de
la glycémie mais on va
voir tu manges un ch perdu j'ai perdu
moi tu sais je les défis je suis les
défis moi Alexandre al Alexandre je suis
d'ca moi bone va venir ah c'est c'est
grave c'est que c'est vraiment grave un
bonb un en bonbon ils sont tous Mo jeoue
place on peut faire un midle là ici le
côéé a vérifié CTA autorisé dans les
lois il va nous donner la réponse dans
un instant peut-on manger un STI en télé
c'est la question que vous êtes
certainement posé tous une fois dans
votre vie Conseil d'État Conseil d'État
s pché dessus on va voir tout de suite
si il est de manger en slip en
audiovisuel
voilàè en tout cas c'est vrai qu'elle a
raison geraline les deux cadeaux de Jean
c'est
den mon
avis al à ton avis à mon avis Raymond ne
peut pas se présenter comme ça et et
manger les
bonbons il peut le faire par contre chez
lui chez lui il peut faire ce qu'il veut
pas les caméras c'est pas diffusé il
fait ce qu'il veut mais sinon à mon avis
est- est-ce que je une est-ce qu'il peut
pas le faire pour les réseaux sur les
réseaux on fait ce qu'on veut donc après
l'émission tu lui boufferas Réau ou
alors ou alors il a porté donc ça compte
il peut le retirer et lu
manger une autre idée et si je me mets
derrière le pupitre les
camér moi les gars j'ai le truc j'ai le
truc pour moi maintenant il y a
plusieurs supports donc on a la toche la
T voilà et on va envoyer les gens sur le
digital puisque à la suite de l'émission
Raymon exactement mangera le slip de de
Hugo voilà et ça fera ça sera une vidé
dernière de l'émission faut qu' m' ou
alors hors caméra hors caméra hors
plateau non non non est Rais c'est pas
les raisons fait ce qu'on veut on va pas
le poster sur tes P le postera sur S sur
ses RA s raau pers RA mais sinon Hugo
peut le
retirerér person en tout cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci